La relativité générale est une des théories
les plus fascinantes de la science moderne.
Je l'ai déjà évoquée plein de fois
quand j'ai parlé des trous noirs,
du big bang, des ondes gravitationnelles
ou de la gravité quantique.
Et pourtant je n'ai jamais vraiment expliqué
en quoi elle consiste.
Quand je dois présenter la relativité
générale en quelques minutes
je m'en sors généralement
avec une image de ce genre
qui permet d'expliquer que d'après
cette théorie,
la gravité n'est plus une force
mais est remplacée
par la courbure de l'espace-temps.
C'est à dire que les corps massifs courbent
l'espace-temps
et les trajectoires des autres corps
alentours se trouvent
modifiées du fait de cette courbure.
Cette petite illustration, elle fonctionne
très bien pour expliquer rapidement l'idée.
Mais si on y réfléchit, elle appelle aussi
plein de questions sur ce qu'est la courbure
et comment on utilise ce concept
pour représenter la gravité.
Et puis quand on regarde cette image,
moi je me suis souvent dit :
" Mais dans quoi l'espace est il courbé ? "
Et bien aujourd'hui, on va essayer
de faire la lumière sur tout ça.
[Musique]
La théorie de la relativité générale
date de 1915
et elle est principalement l’œuvre
d'Albert Einstein.
Et il faut savoir qu'elle est,
en quelque sorte,
la troisième théorie de la relativité.
Einstein avait en effet présenté
dix ans avant
la théorie de la relativité restreinte
qui elle-même peut être vue comme
une amélioration de la relativité galiléenne,
issue des idées de Galilée et Newton
au 17ème siècle.
J'ai déjà fait un épisode spécifique
sur la relativité restreinte.
Je vous le recommande
si vous ne l'avez pas vu,
mais je vais rappeler l'essentiel
de ce qu'il faut savoir
pour aborder aujourd'hui
la relativité générale.
Dans la relativité galiléenne comme
dans la relativité restreinte,
on a besoin de référentiels : des sortes
de grille pour se repérer
qui permettent de caractériser la position
des objets, leur trajectoire
et mesurer le déroulement des événements.
Parmi tous les référentiels possibles,
il en existe une catégorie à part :
les référentiels dits "galiléens".
Un référentiel galiléen, c'est un référentiel
dans lequel un corps qui ne subit aucune
force va tout droit à vitesse constante.
On dit qu'il est en mouvement
rectiligne uniforme.
Évidemment, quand un corps ne subit
aucune force
il peut aussi être immobile
dans un référentiel donné.
Mais "être immobile" est un cas particulier
de mouvement rectiligne uniforme
où on va à vitesse nulle.
Parmi les référentiels galiléens possibles,
on utilise souvent le référentiel terrestre
c'est-à-dire qu'on mesure les trajectoires
par rapport au sol, à la surface de la Terre.
Dans ce référentiel, effectivement,
un corps ne subissant aucune force
est bien soit immobile
soit en mouvement rectiligne uniforme.
Prenons un exemple :
une pierre de curling posée sur la glace
de la patinoire
ne subit que son poids et la réaction
du sol qui le compense exactement.
La force totale qui lui est appliquée
est donc nulle,
c'est comme si elle ne subissait
aucune force.
Donc elle peut être soit immobile
comme ici,
mais si je l'ai propulsée d'un coup sec
auparavant,
au cours de son mouvement la force
sera toujours nulle
et elle ira en mouvement rectiligne
uniforme.
Évidemment j'idéalise un peu puisque
dans la vraie vie
la pierre subit des petites forces
de frottement
et donc elle finira par ralentir
et s'arrêter,
mais sans frottement, elle continuerait
indéfiniment en mouvement rectiligne uniforme.
Un point important concernant
les référentiels galiléens,
c'est qu'à part le référentiel terrestre
il en existe plein d'autres possibles
et tous partagent un lien
ils sont en mouvement rectiligne uniforme
les uns par rapport aux autres.
par exemple n'importe quel véhicule
allant tout droit,
à vitesse constante par rapport au sol,
est un référentiel galiléen possible
et je peux m'en servir pour mesurer
la trajectoire de ma pierre de curling
et dans tous ces référentiels la pierre
ira toujours
en mouvement rectiligne uniforme,
mais tout ça ne marche que quand,
par exemple,
un train va tout droit
et à vitesse constante.
S'il commence à accélérer, à freiner
ou faire des virages
eh bien ça n'est plus un référentiel
galiléen,
la preuve de ça c'est qu'un objet
ne subissant aucune force
par exemple une bille posée
sur le sol du train,
se mettra à rouler si le train tourne,
freine ou accélère,
elle se met en mouvement même
en l'absence de force,
ce qui montre que le référentiel
n'est plus galiléen.
En résumé dans la relativité galiléenne
les référentiels se divisent
en deux catégories : ceux qui sont galiléen
et ceux qui ne sont pas.
Dans les référentiels galiléens les corps
ne subissant aucune force
sont en mouvement rectiligne uniforme,
et pour les autres référentiels
ben ça n'est plus le cas
donc, quand on peut, on les évite.
Bon tout ça c'est s'il n'y a pas
de force appliquée, on l'a dit,
mais s'il y a des forces, ça se passe
comment dans les référentiels galiléens ?
Eh bien il y à la loi de Newton
qui relie la somme des forces
qui s'appliquent "F"
à l'accélération subie "a"
et la masse de l'objet "m".
D'ailleurs on devrait plutôt l'écrire :
c'est-à-dire que si vous connaissez
la force et la masse
vous pouvez en déduire l'accélération,
et c'est cette accélération
qui donnera à notre objet
une trajectoire différente du mouvement
rectiligne uniforme.
Et la beauté de la chose, c'est que
cette équation de Newton,
elle marche de la même manière dans
tous les référentiels galiléens
et ça a une conséquence importante,
il est impossible en faisant des expériences
de physique sur le mouvement des objets,
de distinguer un référentiel galiléen
d'un autre.
Les expériences donnent toujours
les mêmes résultats,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le principe
de relativité.
Vous savez parfois quand votre train
démarre vous avez du mal à savoir
si c'est vraiment votre train qui bouge
ou celui d'à côté.
Eh bien c'est exactement ça qui se passe,
vous n'arrivez pas à distinguer
si vous êtes immobile par rapport
au quai ou dans un train en mouvement.
une version plus sophistiquée de cet argument
c'est d'imaginer un vaisseau spatial,
loin dans l'espace et deux autres vaisseaux
en mouvement rectiligne uniforme
par rapport au premier.
Si dans chacun de ces vaisseaux il y a
un laboratoire
dans lequel on peut faire des expériences
avec des billes, des ressorts, des fluides,
ce que vous voulez, eh bien vous ne verrez
aucune différence
dans les résultats des expériences menées
dans les trois vaisseaux.
Et donc, rien qu'en faisant des expériences,
impossible de savoir dans lequel des trois
vous vous trouvez.
Les référentiels galiléens sont tous
équivalents et impossibles à distinguer.
Tout ce que je viens de vous résumer
sur les référentiels galiléens est essentiel
et il est commun à la relativité galiléenne
et à la relativité restreinte.
Il y a bien sûr des différences entre
ces deux théories
et je vous renvoie à mon épisode
sur le sujet,
mais une différence essentielle
que vous connaissez sans doute
c'est qu'en relativité restreinte,
il existe une vitesse maximum :
la vitesse de la lumière qui est la même
dans tous les référentiels galiléens,
et aucune masse, énergie, ou information
ne peut voyager plus vite.
Et ça, Einstein avait vite compris
que ça posait un problème
avec la description traditionnelle
de la gravité selon Newton.
D'après Newton la gravité qui s'exerce
entre deux objets est une force
et il propose une expression
pour cette force :
le produit des masses divisé
par la distance au carré,
avec une petite constante qu'on appelle
la constante de Newton.
Cette théorie de la gravité de Newton,
elle marche super super bien,
on peut s'en servir notamment pour prédire
le mouvement des planètes
avec une précision en apparence incroyable,
mais le problème qu'elle pose pour Einstein
c'est que, dans la théorie de Newton
cette force agit à distance
et de façon instantanée.
Prenons un exemple fictif : la Terre
tourne autour du soleil,
précisément à cause de l'attraction
de la gravité.
Si on imagine que le soleil disparaît
soudainement,
dans la théorie de Newton la trajectoire
de la Terre devrait être
immédiatement modifiée, ce qui voudrait dire
que l'information gravitationnelle
a voyagé de façon instantanée,
plus vite que la lumière donc !
Et ça faisait une très bonne raison
pour Einstein d'essayer
d'améliorer la théorie de Newton
pour la rendre compatible
avec la relativité restreinte.
[jingle]
Après avoir conçu la théorie
de la relativité restreinte en 1905
Einstein réfléchit donc à "comment la rendre
compatible avec la force de gravité".
Et un jour il a une révélation en pensant
au fait
que tous les objets en chute libre
tombent de la même façon.
Je pense que vous savez que,
dans l'atmosphère,
ça n'est pas exactement le cas à cause
des frottements de l'air,
mais dans le vide ça marche très bien,
une pomme, une plume, un marteau
tombent de façon parfaitement synchronisée,
et c'est vrai quelle que soit la masse,
la forme ou la composition
de ce qu'ont fait tomber.
Cette constatation était évidemment
déjà bien connue avant Einstein,
et pour cause, elle s'explique parfaitement
avec les équations de Newton,
mais vous allez voir que ça repose
sur un petit miracle.
On l'a vu, Newton nous dit
que l'accélération d'un objet est reliée
à la somme des forces subies par a = F / m
vous prenez la force, vous divisez
par la masse de l'objet
et vous avez l'accélération,
mais d'un autre côté
la théorie de la gravité nous dit
que le poids d'un objet est une force
proportionnelle à sa masse,
et qui vaut mg
où g est le champ de pesanteur,
à la surface de la Terre c'est environ
9,8 mètres par seconde carré.
Maintenant si on injecte cette équation
dans la première,
puisque la force de gravité est une force,
la masse se simplifie et il reste s
implement a = g
L'accélération d'un objet est égale
au champ de pesanteur,
quelque soit sa masse, donc tous les objets
en chute libre tombent de la même façon.
Alors pourquoi je dis que c'est un miracle ?
Dans l'équation du poids P = mg,
la masse quantifie la façon dont un objet
réagit au champ de pesanteur.
D'un autre côté dans l'équation a = F / m,
la masse quantifie l'inertie d'un objet,
la difficulté qu'on a à le déplacer
si on lui applique une certaine force.
Et si on y réfléchit, l'inertie n'a
a priori pas de lien avec la pesanteur,
par exemple un gros rocher va être plus
difficile à mettre en mouvement
qu'un petit rocher, même en apesanteur,
indépendamment de la gravité.
Le fait que la masse apparaisse
avec des rôles qui n'ont rien à voir
dans ces deux équations qui ont une origine
très différente,
c'est quand même bizarre, d'ailleurs
on donne parfois des noms différents
à ces deux rôles de la masse.
Dans la formule du poids, on parle
de masse pesante,
et dans f = ma, de masse inerte,
Et tout porte à croire que, de façon
en apparence miraculeuse,
la masse pesante et la masse inerte
d'un objet sont toujours absolument égales.
Il faut bien réaliser que ça n'a rien
d'obligatoire a priori
on pourrait imaginer des corps qui sont
difficiles à bouger, très inertes,
mais peu sensibles aux champs de pesanteur,
ou bien l'inverse,
mais expérimentalement
ça ne se produit jamais.
Pour tous les objets, dans tous
les matériaux,
la masse pesante et la masse inerte
sont rigoureusement égales
et on a testé ça jusqu'à des écarts relatifs
de presque un millionième de milliardième
et, à chaque fois, c'est pareil.
On appelle cette égalité le principe
d'équivalence,
quand on a deux quantités qui a priori
n'ont rien à voir
et qui s'avèrent strictement égales,
ça cache en général un truc profond,
et c'est ce truc profond
qu'a compris Einstein.
Voici son raisonnement : imaginez
que vous soyez dans un ascenseur
à un étage très élevé d'un gratte ciel,
vous tenez une guitare dans une main,
une tasse de café dans l'autre,
et soudain le câble de l'ascenseur lâche
et la cabine tombe.
En chute libre, on l'a dit, tout tombe
de la même façon,
donc la cabine, vous, la guitare, la tasse
allez tomber de façon synchronisée.
Si vous lâchez la guitare, vous allez la voir
flotter à côté de vous,
elle tombe à la même vitesse que vous,
pareil pour la tasse,
si vous lâchez le café va sortir,
former une boule
qui va flotter aussi à côté de vous.
Pendant toute la durée de la chute
vous allez vivre une expérience
qui serait exactement la même que
si vous étiez en apesanteur
dans une cabine au fin fond de l'espace.
Et en pensant à tout ça, Einstein
à l'idée de génie,
il se dit que si dans la cabine d'ascenseur
on installe un laboratoire
avec des boules, des ressorts,
des fluides etc.,
toutes les expériences qu'on pourra faire
pendant la chute libre
donneront exactement les mêmes résultats
que si on les faisait
dans un laboratoire flottant librement
au fin fond de l'espace,
dans un référentiel galiléen.
Pourtant un ascenseur en chute libre
ça ne devrait pas être
un référentiel galiléen, il est
en accélération, eh bien tant pis !
Einstein à l'idée de généraliser
le principe de relativité
en l'élargissant à tous les référentiels
qui sont en chute libre,
dans tous ces référentiels, les résultats
d'expériences physiques
donnent toujours les mêmes résultats
et tous ces référentiels on va les appeler
collectivement les "référentiels inertiels",
mais du coup ce nouveau point de vue
nous oblige
à repenser ce qu'on appelle une force.
Dans la relativité restreinte ou galiléenne,
on l'a dit,
la trajectoire naturelle en l'absence
de forces,
c'est le mouvement rectiligne uniforme
et si des forces s'appliquent elle nous
dévient du mouvement rectiligne uniforme
selon la loi a = F / m.
Dans ce qui va devenir la relativité générale,
la trajectoire naturelle non perturbée,
c'est la chute libre et si on subit
une force F
on dévie de cette trajectoire toujours
selon une loi du genre a = F / m,
avec une grosse différence : maintenant
on ne compte plus la gravité dans les forces.
Tout ça peut ressembler a priori à un tour
de passe-passe,
avant la trajectoire non perturbée
était le mouvement rectiligne uniforme
et on comptait toutes les forces
pour la perturber,
maintenant la trajectoire non perturbée
est la chute libre
et on ne compte plus la gravité
dans les forces.
En gros on a pris la gravité à un endroit
et on l'a mis à un autre,
ça semble revenir au même non ?
Et pourtant on va voir que ce changement
de point de vue a des conséquences.
Imaginez un espace dans lequel il n'y ait
aucun corps massif,
les trajectoires naturelles sont bien
les mouvements rectilignes uniformes,
en l'absence de gravité le mouvement
rectiligne uniforme
est une trajectoire de chute libre.
Maintenant si j'ajoute un corps massif
je modifie ces trajectoires
qui deviennent autre chose que des mouvements
rectilignes uniformes,
ce sont les nouvelles trajectoires
de chute libre.
Notez au passage qu'ici plusieurs
de ses trajectoires sont
ce qu'on appelle traditionnellement
des orbites
mais une orbite est une chute libre.
Oui oui, la Lune est en permanence
en chute libre vers la Terre.
Et le point essentiel dans cette histoire,
c'est que pour un point de départ
et une vitesse initiale donnés,
la trajectoire qu'on obtient est la même
quels que soient l'objet, sa forme,
sa masse, sa composition.
On pourrait donc, si on voulait, dresser
une cartographie de toutes ces trajectoires
et c'est comme si elles étaient devenues
une propriété associée à l'espace-temps
lui-même.
Et c'est cette idée qui motive le fait
de changer de point de vue,
les corps massifs ne créent pas
un champ de gravité,
ils n'affectent pas directement
les autres objets,
mais ils modifient les trajectoires
naturelles de l'espace temps.
Le problème c'est : qu'est ce que
ça veut dire concrètement
de modifier les trajectoires naturelles ?
Un petit argument pour nous guider :
on l'a dit, une trajectoire de chute libre
n'est pas un mouvement rectiligne uniforme,
ça se voit bien car ce sont des trajectoires
où on accélère, mais pas seulement…
Imaginez deux objets situés à quelques
milliers de kilomètres
de la surface de la Terre et à un mètre
de distance l'un de l'autre.
Si on lâche ces objets sans vitesse initiale
ils vont tous les deux commencer
à suivre leur trajectoire naturelle
et à tomber de façon parallèle,
Mais si on regarde les choses vues de loin,
en exagérant un peu les échelles
pour que ce soit clair,
vu que ces deux objets se dirigent
vers le centre de la Terre,
eh bien ils vont se rapprocher au fur
et à mesure de leur chute.
Donc on a deux trajectoires qui initialement
sont parallèles,
mais qui finalement se rapprochent,
ça vous évoque peut être quelque chose,
c'est un phénomène typique
des géométries courbes.
Vous savez peut-être que le grec Euclide
avait défini des axiomes
pour faire de la géométrie dans le plan
et l'un d'eux était :
quand on prend une droite et un point
en dehors de cette droite,
il existe une et une seule parallèle
à la droite, qui passe par ce point.
Bien plus tard, au 19e siècle
on s'est rendu compte
qu'on pouvait changer cet axiome et obtenir
d'autres formes de géométrie
qu'on appelle donc non-euclidiennes.
Sur des espaces courbes on peut avoir
plusieurs parallèles
qui passent par le même point,
et de façon générale
bien que ça paraisse contre-intuitif,
des parallèles peuvent se croiser,
se rapprocher ou s'éloigner.
Cette idée de trajectoires parallèles
qui se rapprochent,
c'est justement ce qu'on observe
avec nos trajectoires de chute libre,
et c'est comme ça qu'est née l'idée
d'utiliser la géométrie courbe
pour représenter la gravité.
Et pour essayer de donner un sens précis
à cette idée,
Einstein a utilisé un outil mathématique
qui était à l'époque encore assez récent :
la géométrie de Riemann.
[Jingle]
Riemann était un mathématicien du 19e siècle
qui a notamment formalisé la notion
d'espace courbe.
Intuitivement, quand on pense à la notion
de courbure,
on pense à l'idée de quelque chose de tordu.
Voici une ligne droite,
voici une ligne courbe,
voici une surface plane,
voici une surface courbe,
à chaque fois on a l'impression
que pour courber
on a besoin d'une dimension supplémentaire
Une ligne courbe on la dessine dans un plan,
une surface courbée on a besoin de la tordre
dans l'espace, dans la troisième dimension,
du coup comment on fait pour avoir un espace
à trois dimensions qui soit courbe ?
Et encore pire, un espace-temps
à quatre dimensions qui soit courbe,
est-ce qu'il faut faire appel
à une dimension supplémentaire,
une 5ème dimension, dans laquelle
l'espace-temps se courberait ?
Et du coup elle serait où
cette 5ème dimension ?
Et bien ce qu'on va voir maintenant,
c'est que, mathématiquement,
on n'a absolument pas besoin d'une dimension
supplémentaire pour parler de courbure.
Si on observe une surface comme celle-ci
dont on est d'accord qu'elle est courbe,
à part le fait d'être tordue, qu'est-ce qui
nous révèle qu'elle est courbe ?
Eh bien il y a une chose
qu'on peut remarquer,
c'est que la courbure change la notion de
"plus court chemin d'un point à un autre".
Sur une surface plane le chemin le plus court
entre deux points c'est la ligne droite,
mais si j'ajoute de la courbure et que
je représente ça de façon traditionnelle
c'est-à-dire en tordant la surface
vous voyez que le chemin le plus court
entre ces deux points
sera peut-être celui ci.
Une manière de le formuler c'est de dire
que ce qui caractérise un espace courbe,
c'est que la ligne droite
n'est plus nécessairement
le chemin le plus court
d'un point à un autre.
Prenez un planisphère, vous savez
une représentation de la Terre à plat.
Imaginez que vous deviez faire le trajet
en avion de Paris à Montréal,
intuitivement on pourrait penser
que le plus court chemin est celui-ci,
mais en fait non, le voici.
Si vous n'êtes pas convaincus
c'est plus facile
quand on regarde effectivement
le globe terrestre,
bien que Paris et Montréal soient
approximativement à la même latitude,
le chemin le plus court n'est pas de rester
sur cette latitude,
mais de remonter légèrement vers le nord.
À cause de la représentation
sur le planisphère,
on a l'impression que cette trajectoire
n'est pas droite
mais à y regarder de plus près est-ce que
vous en êtes vraiment sûrs ?
Poussons à l'extrême, prenez 2 points
proches du pôle nord, à la même latitude.
Vous ne pensez pas que c'est ça
la ligne droite
au lieu de ça ?
Plutôt que de dire que dans
les espaces courbes
le chemin le plus court n'est plus
la ligne droite,
il faut changer de point de vue et dire
que c'est le concept même de ligne droite
qui se trouve modifié
dans les espaces courbes.
Une ligne droite c'est ce qu'on obtient
en avançant toujours dans la même direction
et dans un espace courbe, eh bien on peut
définir la notion de
"avancer dans la même direction"
et elle nous fait obtenir des trajectoires
qui, si elles ne sont pas forcément intuitives,
sont bien les trajectoires
de plus court chemin.
Pour éviter de se perdre, on va leur donner
un nom différent de "lignes droites",
on va les appeler des "géodésiques".
Donc en résumé, dans un espace courbe
en avançant toujours dans la même direction
on obtient des trajectoires géodésiques,
et le chemin le plus court d'un point
à un autre est toujours une géodésique.
À part la présentation des géodésiques,
il existe une autre manière
de caractériser le fait que la Terre
soit courbe,
même quand on la représente sous la forme
d'un planisphère,
c'est que les distances sont déformées.
Regardez ici, le Groenland a l'air de faire
à peu près la même taille que l'Afrique,
alors qu'en réalité sa superficie
est 15 fois moindre.
Une autre façon le dire : l'échelle varie
partout sur cette carte,
un centimètre au centre de la carte
représente une distance réelle
bien plus grande qu'un centimètre ici
ou là.
Et vous devinez peut-être que c'est lié
à cette idée de chemin le plus court,
si le chemin le plus court pour aller
à Montréal depuis Paris
c'est de passer par là plutôt que par ici,
c'est parce que 1 cm dans cette zone
représente en réalité
moins de kilomètres que 1 cm dans celle ci.
En conclusion on voit qu'on a deux façons
reliées
de caractériser le fait qu'un espace
soit courbe
d'un côté les lignes droites, les géodésiques,
ne sont pas celles qu'on aurait
dans un espace plat,
et de l'autre la manière dont on calcule
les distances
peut varier d'un point à un autre de l'espace.
Pour pouvoir utiliser ces notions
géométriques
pour faire des calculs physiques,
ce qui est important
c'est de pouvoir les représenter
avec des nombres
et une manière de le faire c'est de penser
au théorème de Pythagore.
Dans un espace plat si on veut calculer
la distance entre deux points,
on peut utiliser le théorème de Pythagore.
La distance au carré est égale à
l'écart en x au carré plus
l'écart en y au carré.
Eh bien ce qu'il faut s'imaginer c'est que
dans un espace courbe,
cette formule ne marche plus,
ou plutôt elle peut prendre
une forme modifiée.
Une façon de la modifier c'est d'ajouter
des coefficients ici, là
et pourquoi pas un terme en plus qui mélange
l'écart en x et l'écart en y.
Ce que je viens de vous représenter là
c'est un des objets mathématiques
les plus importants
quand on fait de la relativité générale,
on l'appelle "la métrique".
La métrique, c'est ce tableau de coefficients
qu'on utilise
pour montrer comment les calculs
de distances s'écartent
du bon vieux théorème de Pythagore,
et on la note : petit g.
Et ce qui est important c'est que la métrique
peut varier d'un point à un autre,
comme on l'a vu sur le planisphère
où les distances
ne se calculent pas de la même façon partout.
Il faut s'imaginer que c'est parce que
les coefficients qu'on utilise
dans la métrique changent suivant l'endroit.
La métrique suffit à elle seule,
à représenter
toute l'information sur la courbure
d'un espace.
Quand on connaît la métrique et qu'on peut
calculer des distances,
on peut alors retrouver les chemins
les plus courts
et reconstruire les géodésiques, il existe
même une équation pour ça :
l'équation des géodésiques.
Ce qui est important dans tout
ce qu'on vient de dire,
c'est que ces notions-là n'impliquent
pas du tout d'avoir une dimension de plus
dans laquelle courber les choses.
Un espace courbe c'est un espace
dans lequel la métrique,
la manière dont on calcule la distance,
n'est plus celle d'un espace plat
le bon vieux théorème de Pythagore,
et les géodésiques deviennent du coup
autre chose que des lignes droites,
et ça, ça marche sans dimension de plus.
Imaginez que je vous donne un certain espace
et je vous dis : voici ses géodésiques,
ça suffit à définir qu'il est courbé,
et pas besoin d'une dimension supplémentaire.
Autre exemple en forme d'analogie :
vous savez que si vous regardez une carte
d'une grande métropole,
le temps mis pour aller d'un point
à un autre n'est pas du tout lié
à la distance sur la carte, ça dépend
du réseau de transport en commun
ou des embouteillages.
Eh bien en quelque sorte, on peut dire
que les grandes villes sont
des espaces courbes et pourtant elles n'ont
pas une dimension supplémentaire.
Bien, faisons un petit bilan, on a montré
qu'on pouvait parler de courbure
sans avoir besoin d'une dimension en plus,
et qu'une différence majeure entre un espace
courbe et un espace plat
ce sont les géodésiques qui ne sont plus
des lignes droites traditionnelles.
Et ça tombe bien, c'est exactement
ce qu'on veut
pour dire que les trajectoires naturelles
non perturbées
ne sont plus des lignes droites,
mais des trajectoires éventuellement
plus compliquées
qui peuvent notamment se rapprocher
ou s'éloigner.
Avant d'aller plus loin
une petite précision :
je vous ai principalement parlé ici
de la courbure d'un espace,
en réalité pour la relativité générale
on doit parler d'espace-temps.
Ça introduit quelques subtilités
par rapport à ce que je vous ai dit,
mais je vous les épargne.
Il nous reste une question à résoudre,
dans cette histoire il faut qu'on soit
capable de relier la quantité de courbure
à la quantité de matière puisque
c'est la matière qui courbe l'espace-temps.
Plus il y a de matière,
plus il y a de gravité,
donc plus il doit y avoir de courbure.
Et pour ça on a envie d'écrire une équation
du genre : courbure égale masse !
Sauf que pour tout un tas de raisons
sur lesquelles je passe,
ce qui marche ce n'est pas de mettre
dans courbure la métrique
comme on pourrait intuitivement le penser
mais un truc plus compliqué, qui dépend
de la métrique
et qu'on appelle le "tenseur d'Einstein"
et on le note grand G.
De l'autre côté on va mettre
un autre truc compliqué
qu'on appelle le tenseur
énergie-impulsion-contraintes
qui est une sorte de généralisation
des notions de masse et d'énergie
et de leurs flux respectifs
et donc voilà la grande équation
de la relativité générale.
Cette équation, Einstein ne l'a pas trouvé
tout de suite,
il a pas mal tâtonné et fait
plusieurs essais infructueux.
Et pour ça il a été principalement guidé
par un truc très important.
Quand on propose comme ça une nouvelle théorie
pour remplacer la gravité de Newton,
eh bien il faut au moins s'assurer
qu'elle donne à peu près
les mêmes résultats dans les cas où on sait
que Newton fonctionne bien
c'est-à-dire essentiellement pour des champs
gravitationnels faibles
et des vitesses très inférieures
à celle de la lumière.
Et c'est cette exigence de retrouver
la théorie de Newton dans ces conditions
qui a mis Einstein sur la piste
de la bonne équation.
L'équation d'Einstein qui fixe la manière
dont la courbure dépend du contenu en matière
de l'espace-temps
vous ne pouvez pas la résoudre
directement comme ça,
Elle est très compliquée car le tenseur
d'Einstein
est une fonction très non-linéaire
de la métrique.
Le mieux qu'on puisse faire c'est
de la résoudre dans des cas particuliers.
Donc pour en trouver des solutions
on se fixe des situations simples
et on essaye de voir si on peut trouver
une métrique qui résolve l'équation.
Prenons une première situation,
celle où on a un objet de masse M,
parfaitement sphérique,
qui déforme l'espace-temps.
On peut dans ce cas, trouver une métrique
qui résout l'équation d'Einstein,
c'est la métrique qui décrit la déformation
des distances dans l'espace-temps
autour d'une masse sphérique, on l'appelle
la métrique de Schwarzschild,
Elle dépend de la distance r à laquelle
on se trouve du centre de la masse,
plus on est proche, plus le calcul
des distances est déformé par la courbure.
Alors que si on est loin de la masse,
on retrouve une métrique d'un espace plat
puisque on ne sent plus l'influence
de cette masse.
Pour des masses M très élevées et
quand on se trouve très proche
cette métrique nous permet de comprendre
l'existence des trous noirs,
mais ça c'est un autre épisode.
Un point important c'est que si
on prend cette métrique
et qu'on se place dans le cas précis
d'une masse M pas trop élevée
et de vitesses d'objets qui sont
très inférieures à celle de la lumière,
eh bien elle prend une forme plus simple.
Forme qu'on peut ensuite utiliser
pour calculer les géodésiques
c'est-à-dire les trajectoires
de chute libre
et on voit alors qu'on retrouve exactement
les trajectoires qu'on a
avec la loi de Newton
et c'est une bonne nouvelle, on l'a dit,
dans les situations
où la loi de Newton fonctionne bien,
il est indispensable que la relativité
générale fournisse le même résultat.
Autre possibilité on peut aussi regarder
l'équation d'Einstein
dans le cas de déformations faibles
de l'espace-temps,
mais pas forcément par un objet sphérique,
c'est comme ça qu'on peut décrire
les ondes gravitationnelles.
Ces ondes sont des déformations
de l'espace-temps
qui se propagent à la même vitesse
que la lumière,
elles traduisent le fait
qu'en relativité générale,
contrairement à la théorie de Newton,
l'influence de la gravité n'est
pas instantanée à distance
mais prend un certain temps à voyager.
Donc la relativité générale résout bien
le problème initial qu'avait Einstein :
la compatibilité entre la gravité
et le fait que rien ne peut aller
plus vite que la lumière.
Et ces ondes gravitationnelles n'existaient
pas dans la théorie de Newton évidemment,
elles sont donc bien une prédiction nouvelle
spécifique de la relativité générale,
Qui a d'ailleurs été confirmée récemment,
les détecteurs ligot et virgo ont observé
les ondes créées
par la fusion de deux trous noirs situés
à 1,3 milliards d'années-lumière,
des ondes qui ont donc mis 1,3 milliard
d'années pour nous parvenir.
Fascinant non ?
Autre cas d'application de l'équation
d'Einstein
et de la relativité générale : le big bang.
Je ferai un jour un épisode complet
sur le sujet,
mais si vous prenez les équations d'Einstein
dans le cas particulier d'un univers homogène
et isotrope,
c'est-à-dire similaire partout
et dans toutes les directions,
vous obtenez des équations beaucoup
plus simples,
qui servent de base aux modèles
cosmologiques.
L'idée d'expansion de l'univers découle
donc des équations de la relativité générale,
mais historiquement, ce qui a permis
d'apporter les premières confirmations
à la théorie de la relativité générale,
ce sont des observations faisables
au sein du système solaire.
[jingle]
Je vous ai dit que pour ce qui concerne
le mouvement des planètes
les équations de Newton font merveilleusement
bien le travail,
il y a toutefois une petite exception,
le mouvement de la planète Mercure.
Comme toutes les planètes du système solaire
l'orbite de Mercure ne décrit pas exactement
un cercle, mais une ellipse.
C'est même la planète dont l'orbite
est la plus elliptique,
mais à cause de l'influence que toutes
les planètes ont les unes sur les autres,
l'ellipse elle-même tourne au cours du temps,
on dit qu'elle précesse,
dans la théorie de Newton on peut calculer
la vitesse de cette précession,
c'est-à-dire la vitesse à laquelle
l'ellipse tourne.
C'est un calcul assez pénible, mais
si on le fait
pour toutes les planètes du système solaire
on trouve la bonne valeur,
celle qu'on peut mesurer par des observations
astronomiques…
sauf pour Mercure !
Pour Mercure il y a une petite différence
entre la valeur mesurée et celle prédite.
Dans la théorie de Newton, l'ellipse tourne
à 0,148° par siècle
et la valeur mesurée c'est 0,159° par siècle.
Et évidemment, devinez quoi, Einstein
a constaté qu'en prenant son équation
et en refaisant le calcul on tombait
sur une valeur de 0,159° par siècle.
La relativité générale avait passé
son 1er test.
Le 2ème test eut lieu quelques années
plus tard, en 1919,
et il concerne la déviation
des rayons lumineux.
La première chose à savoir c'est que,
effectivement, en relativité générale,
la lumière est déviée par les déformations
de l'espace-temps,
c'est une conséquence assez logique
du principe d'équivalence.
On l'a dit, dans une cabine isolée
dans l'espace
et dans une cabine en chute libre,
les résultats d'expériences doivent
être les mêmes.
Si je tire un rayon lumineux
dans la première il va aller tout droit,
or si la lumière ne subissait pas la gravité,
eh bien dans la cabine en chute libre
on verrait une déviation de ce genre,
et donc on serait capable de savoir
qu'on est en chute libre
plutôt qu'en apesanteur totale ce qui irait
à l'encontre du principe d'équivalence.
Et donc si le principe d'équivalence
est correct,
la lumière doit suivre la courbure
de l'espace-temps.
Cette idée que la lumière soit attiré
par la gravité
elle a déjà été envisagée dans le cadre
de la gravité de Newton,
mais bien plus tardivement et de façon
pas forcément très satisfaisante,
alors que dans la relativité générale,
on peut précisément
calculer la manière dont la déformation
de l'espace-temps influence
la trajectoire des rayons lumineux.
Puisque un rayon lumineux, comme tous
les corps, doit suivre une géodésique.
Concrètement un rayon lumineux émis par
une étoile et qui passe à côté du soleil
est légèrement dévié, alors pas grand chose,
environ 0,5 millièmes de degré,
beaucoup moins que ce que je représente
sur le schéma évidemment.
Le problème c'est qu'une déviation si petite
c'est pas simple à mettre en évidence
notamment parce que quand la lumière
d'une étoile passe proche du soleil
et arrive sur Terre, ben c'est forcément
que l'étoile se trouve pour nous
dans la direction du soleil, et du coup
on ne la voit pas,
à cause du contraste on est ébloui
par le soleil.
Le seul moment où on a une chance,
c'est lors d'une éclipse totale.
Le 29 mai 1919, quatre ans après
la publication de la théorie,
une occasion en or s'est justement présentée
car il y a eu une éclipse totale visible
dans l'hémisphère sud.
Des expéditions coordonnées par l'astronome
Arthur Eddington,
ont été prendre des photos du soleil
et surtout de ce qu'on voyait
en arrière-plan,
pour voir si la position apparente
des étoiles était modifiée
et là, à nouveau, bingo !
Les images ou en effet révélé une déviation
de la position des étoiles
par rapport à ce qu'on aurait attendu,
ce qui confirmait les calculs Einstein
et venait en support
de sa théorie de la relativité générale.
C'est d'ailleurs à partir de cette annonce,
qui a eu un certain écho
dans la presse mondiale,
qu'Einstein a commencé à devenir célèbre,
jusqu'à être la superstar connaît.
Depuis on a pu observer le phénomène
de déviation de la lumière
de façon un peu différente,
sur des images astronomiques
En effet si une source lumineuse est située
juste dans l'axe d'un objet massif,
il se peut que les rayons lumineux
qu'elle émet soient déviés
de part et d'autre et finissent pour nous
par former plusieurs images de la source.
On peut alors observer le phénomène dit
de "croix d'Einstein"
avec plusieurs images de la même
source lumineuse
ou carrément ce qu'on appelle
un "anneau d'Einstein",
il y a plein d'images en forme de cercle.
De façon plus générale on parle d'effet
de lentille gravitationnelle.
Il existe encore d'autres prédictions
de la relativité générale
qui découlent les équations d'Einstein,
comme par exemple le phénomène
de dilatation du temps,
ce phénomène est la version relativité
générale du paradoxe des jumeaux,
je ferai un épisode sur le sujet un jour,
mais l'idée est de prendre deux horloges
synchronisée partant du même endroit,
d'en amener une dans un champ
de gravité intense
c'est-à-dire là où l'espace-temps
est très courbé
et de les réunir à nouveau plus tard
pour les comparer.
Eh bien l'horloge qui aura séjourné
dans la zone fortement courbée
sera en retard par rapport à l'autre,
pour elle il se sera écoulé moins de temps
que pour la première.
Évidemment si on fait ça avec des jumeaux
on a un paradoxe des jumeaux,
et c'est ce phénomène qui est par exemple
un des ressorts narratifs du film
"Interstellar" de Christopher Nolan,
pour ceux qui l'ont vu.
À ce jour, la relativité générale reste
une des théories scientifiques les mieux
confirmées expérimentalement.
Aussi bizarre qu'elle soit,
avec ces histoires
de trous noirs et d'espace-temps
en expansion.
Alors on lit régulièrement dans la presse
des titres disant :
telle expérience prouve qu'Einstein
avait raison une fois de plus !
Mais en fait c'est l'inverse,
on devrait titrer :
"telle expérience échoue à prouver
qu Einstein avait tort".
Ben oui, ça marche toujours comme ça
en sciences :
on a une théorie et on essaye de la mettre
en défaut
pour pouvoir éventuellement l'améliorer,
comme ce qu'on a fait avec
la théorie de Newton.
Mais à ce jour, plus de 100 ans
après sa formulation,
la théorie de la relativité générale
semble encore bien solide.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
je vous l'ai dit
plein d'autres épisodes qui détaillent
des conséquences
de la relativité générale dont on a parlé.
Et pour cet épisode en particulier
j'ai mis comme d'habitude plein de précisions
plus ou moins techniques
dans le billet de blog
qui accompagne la vidéo.
Comme toujours Facebook, Twitter,
abonnez-vous, la cloche,
et on se retrouve prochainement
pour des nouvelles vidéos.
À bientôt !
– Sous-titrage : Le Crayon d'oreille -